I think that at the time Catwoman had a
really cool pair of glasses in the
Batman series that was on television and
I wanted to be cool like her it didn't
occur to me that glasses were really a
medical device when light rays reflect
off an object and enter the eye through
the cornea your retina converts this
light into electrical impulses that are
sent to the brain which interprets
thetan pulses and allows you to
understand what you're seeing eye
glasses help you see the earliest forms
of eye gear can be traced back 4,000
years cultures that needed to adapt to
climates that were snowing he created
eyes shields and they were made of bones
and animal hides they had small slits
for people to see through but no lenses
the first vision aid was called a
reading stone and was invented over
1,000 years ago it's not exactly clear
who invented the first eyeglasses
but many people attribute it to the
Italians early versions of eyeglasses
were called rivet spectacles they were
two magnifying glasses that were hinged
together at the bridge of the nose it
took some time for my glasses to land on
the perfect design they didn't really
have sides which are also called temples
or arms until about the 17th century
modern-day my glasses feature a pair of
rims that hold corrective lenses a
bridge that connects the rims sides that
slide behind the ears hinges that
connect the sides to the frames and on
sunglasses a pair of temple tips for
behind the ear Comfort in American
culture 20th century cinema helped
popularize eyeglasses
would see glamorous actresses and actors
donning glasses to take on a different
persona sometimes a pair of glasses
became popularized by the actual person
that was wearing them and then that
personality trait was projected into the
actual device you had the aviator
glasses which showed a forward-thinking
adventurous type of person glasses with
heavy frames signified intelligence or
nerdiness Wayfarers signified this kind
of nerdy punk the outlaw the misfit
glasses have become so popular as a
fashion device that some people actually
Don glasses without a prescription lens
at all because they want to portray a
certain attribute about themselves
glasses are lifeline to people people
that can't see well enough to drive well
enough to cook well enough to read rely
on glasses for maintaining their lives
and there's lots of other objects in our
society that have been created to help
overcome various physical obstacles and
it's only the eyeglasses that have
catapulted to that fashion statement
wouldn't it be wonderful if anything
that we use any device that we've
invented to help our humanity could also
be elevated in the same way
[Music]